I'd like to welcome you again to today's
webinar entitled strategic risk
management in health care taking
healthcare erm to the next level today's
session is being sponsored by the
Stanford center for professional
development and the strategic decision
and risk management certificate program
my name is Hannah winter and I'm a
partner at FEG an associate program
director of the Stanford strategic
decision and risk management program
today I have an esteemed group of
colleagues with me I'd like to spend a
few minutes introducing the folks you'll
hear from today two of our speakers Jeff
Driver and Ed Hall are from Stanford
Hospital and Clinics risk consulting
Jeff driver currently serves as a chief
risk officer an executive vice president
within the Stanford University Medical
Center and directs its risk management
consulting division Stanford hospitals
and clinics risk consulting Jeff has
more than 25 years of experience as a
risk management professional managing
enterprise risk in community tertiary
and academic medical centers welcome
Jeff thank you good morning ed Hall
currently serves as a senior director of
risk management lost control and
education for Stanford University
Medical Center and as a managing
director of Stanford Hospital and
Clinics risk consulting and has more
than 15 years of diverse lost control
and safety management experience with a
particular emphasis in managing worker
safety risks in healthcare and
industrial sectors welcome ed thanks
Anna Sean cilona leads SDGs risk
management initiative and as an
instructor in a Stanford center for
professional development enterprise risk
management course and our new course in
strategic decision-making to manage risk
in health care organization sean has a
law degree in more than 25 years of
experience in consulting welcome John
Thank You Hannah good to be here
Karissa little is the director for
professional program at the Stanford
center for professional development she
has been with Stanford University for
almost 10 years and is responsible for
collaborating with Stanford faculty
industry experts and corporate partners
to develop the professional and
executive programs
extend stanford to industry she worked
in both software and education prior to
coming to Stanford
welcome Karissa Thank You Hannah now
that you know about us we'd like to know
more about you which of the following
describes you best
are you a healthcare risk management for
a professional do you manage healthcare
risk but not in a traditional risk
management function are you a risk
management professional but not specific
to health care are you a participant in
the strategic decision and risk
management program please pick the
response that describes you the best
okay great it looks like many of you are
responding so I'll close the polls and
show the results looks like most of you
are healthcare risk management
professionals we're delighted to have
you here and we hope that this program
is very relevant to the issues that you
deal with every day we're going to start
by talking about where healthcare ERM
has been and what the challenges are we
will then address the three learning
objectives for this session
why leading manager of risk are focused
on risk and uncertainty why it's
possible and necessary to qualify all
major sources of risk and uncertainty by
focusing on risk and uncertainty allows
value protection and value creation and
then we'll then talk about where else
healthcare ERM is going and why and
finally where you can learn more about
this topic now I'd like to turn it over
to Jeff we'll talk about where
healthcare ERM has been and what the
major challenges are okay once again
good morning and good afternoon to those
on the East Coast and beyond as many of
you in the audience know the management
of risk in complex health care
organizations is usually very
decentralized with often separate and
distinct programs managed by various
leaders across the organization as this
diagram illustrates the management of
organizational risk has historically
evolved into
separate silos of what I coin niche risk
management's area such as starting on
the left
ristin and compliance activity at the
organizational governance level business
continuity activities regulatory
compliance internal audit and worker
safety functions insurance in an
alternative risk transfer decision
support and finally clinical risk
quality and patient safety functions the
formal and holistic collaboration and
integration between these niche risk
management areas is not commonly found
in American healthcare management
systems but rather more commonly it is
dependent on informal points of
integration and collaboration between
the various leaders of these niche risk
management areas the other aspect of
managing total risk program value as
many of you have heard is that managing
risk is not just about protecting that
value but about creating or squeezing
out additional value creating and
enhancing value is often referred to as
the upset of risk or as we indicate on
this slide
upside uncertainty this is a very
powerful concept in these recent
economic times and will continue to be
imperative for leading risk managers to
learn about and integrate into their
risk management practice a Stanford
University Medical Center as you will
soon hear from my colleagues we have
been weaving upside risk analysis tools
into our risk management processes as
well as strategic and business planning
with great success for the medical
enterprise I'll now turn it over to
John's fellow Dow who will discuss why
leading managers of risk are focusing on
risk and uncertainty thank you Jeff we
start with considering what is a risk
and why leading managers of risk are
also focusing on uncertainty
the dictionary and common understanding
defined risk as exposure to chance of
injury or loss it's all about the bad
things that could happen to you
thus risk management began as trying to
prevent mitigate or insure against
possible bad events trying to redefine
risk to include the upside handles an
important issue but sometimes just seems
to add to the confusion
instead we like to broaden our thinking
to include uncertainty which includes
naught which includes everything that is
not definitely ascertainable or fixed as
to when it will occur or in what
quantity for health care organizations
there are many daunting uncertainties
not easily handled by lost control or
loss avoidance methods aimed primarily
at bad events for example how many
patients will be coming through your
door over the next decade and what kind
of services will they need what staff
and equipment will you require to meet
those needs
what will your patients and insurers be
willing and able to pay for and lastly
perhaps one of the biggest and
uncertainties of all how all of these be
impacted by healthcare reform the task
gets even harder when you start
considering major decisions such as
acquiring a hospital acquiring a
hospital brings a slew of known kinds of
risks such as workers compensation
claims medical malpractice claims
vehicle liability and so on it also
brings with it a whole lot of all too
real uncertainties like what competing
facilities in your area will do how much
key staff you'll retain what kind of
combined cost savings you realize effect
on reputation and what future revenue
growth of the acquired hospital will be
all these need to be considered but
people are not good at doing all this in
their head it's just too complex
I'll ask Anna to put up the next poll to
consider whether in your organization
you include risk
and uncertainties in your risk
management so let's look at this next
poll
do you consider uncertainties where the
outcome is not known in addition to
risks like chance of loss or injury
please select the answer that best
corresponds to how you handle it in your
organization do you systematically do
that or rarely or never do it great it
looks like many of you are responding so
I'm going to close the polls and show
the results it looks like most of you
sometimes consider them consider
uncertainties but you don't
systematically elicit them in addition
to risk factors Thank You Hannah we all
know our mission is to create the most
value for all our stakeholders patients
staff regulators owners and community
but have you considered how that value
is itself uncertain it depends on all
the same sorts of uncertain factors we
just listed in the context of acquiring
a hospital one way to think of the
overarching job of the board and the CEO
is to increase this uncertain value
which shifts the distribution over to
the right for more value and to reduce
the risk which narrows the distribution
when we think about the uncertainty this
way you see how responsibilities for the
total uncertainty in value splits among
organizational roles but the need for
uncertainty management cuts across the
entire enterprise
the downside risks are managed by the
CRO or risk managers who are charged
with avoiding mitigating or transferring
the risk from potential bad events in
particular the CFO is charged with
staying on top of the financial safety
risk so no one stays up at night
worrying about insolvency
the middle part of the distribution the
day-to-day operations are managed by the
people who handle your clinical
operations insurance and billing and so
forth they manage all the normal risks
and uncertainties in the enterprise on
the right side the corporate development
or strategy folks are charged with
creating the future upside for the
enterprise new facilities or practices
which will drive prosperity going into
the future it's very unlikely that your
facility still has a polio ward but just
how much resources should go to dealing
with bariatric pages patients versus
investing more in orthopedics or
oncology grappling with these
uncertainties though is critical for
creating value and is why managers of
risk who broaden their thinking to
include uncertainty become leaders who
create value in addition to protecting
against loss I'll now ask Edie hall to
talk about how by thinking along these
lines they managed to turn the safe
patient handling program at Stanford
into one which is in garnered numerous
awards and recognitions including an
award for best practices it thanks John
patient handling and movement was a
primary loss driver in our workers
compensation area moving patients that
are not self ambulatory as a high-risk
activity that puts our healthcare
workers and patients at risk for injury
we now had to find a solution to this
costly occurrence in our healthcare
organization we illustrate on this slide
the patient mobility of our population
base this illustration pictures the
capital equipment that would be needed
to address this challenge now to justify
the program we started with data on
employee injuries from pace from
handling patients this got our arms
around the risk of employee injuries we
were hoping to prevent in there cost
each category represents the transfers
that happen within the organization and
the costs associated with those
transfers from a workers compensation
perspective this allowed us to show to
show that you will have to address
several issues and all the equipment on
previous side would be necessary to
address such a complex concern we also
had data on the lost and restricted days
from patient handling injuries the first
level of looking at the data from the
risk events we were trying to prevent
was enough to justify program for our
existing facility using this data we
calculated internal rate of return for
the program of 27 percent with a hurdle
rate of 15 percent this was enough
however we ran into problems trying to
put together a overhead lift program for
the new hospital Stanford Hospital and
Clinics is building there was an effort
to contain costs from a pre-construction
budget based on just the risk data we
had put together the program didn't look
good enough and it was at risk to be cut
we knew there were other real tangible
benefits we got from the program but
they were uncertain and we didn't have
the data to quantify them things like
reduction and pressure ulcers and maybe
even reduce employee turnover the
physical demands of the job are the
single biggest reason given for leaving
the nursing profession and we knew it
cost around sixty thousand dollars to
recruit and train new nurses we needed
some way to quantify and show total
value of the program not just the items
we had historic historical data to
support
I'll ask John now to talk about why it
was possible and necessary to quantify
all the major sources of uncertainty and
risk thank you Edie in our data-driven
world the first question we hit
regarding any proposition is where is
your data to support it
make no mistake collecting and
understanding the data is absolutely
necessary but the problem with relying
only on data is that for the questions
were most interested in what will happen
in the future
there isn't any data nor will there be
any until you've gone and done something
and it's too late that doesn't mean you
should ignore things just because
there's no data not quantifying a risk
or uncertainty can be even worse
words such as likely or unlikely hide
considerable ambiguity and people
usually disagree on what likely means
when you ask them to put a number to it
what's more without quantification
there's no way to measure the
effectiveness of risk mitigation even
Risk rankings become a matter of
personality and politics there is a
proven theoretically sound way of
filling this gap with subjective
probability estimates it involves
careful use of assessment assessment
methods to get the best opinions from
experts and expressing those opinions as
a number you're already quite familiar
with these only you probably don't
realize it last week when I checked the
forecast of rain today for the San
Francisco Bay Area
there was a 10% chance of rain that
doesn't mean that the forecaster looked
at all the historical weather data for
November 16th and it rained 10% of those
days nor does it mean that 10% of today
it will be raining the 10% chance is the
forecasters subjective estimate for the
chance of some rain today given
everything he or she knows about the
weather patterns and how they're moving
around that's what we mean by a
subjective estimate it is your experts
best guess as to the chance something
will happen
it's just expressed as a number to
remove the ambiguity around descriptions
like unlikely versus very unlikely I'll
repeat we always Canon need to look at
the data but in addition to not
quantifying uncertainty where people
repeatedly go wrong is relying only on
historical data relying on historical
data analysis is only appropriate when
you have a stable system and significant
statistically significant data set it
works great for life insurance mortality
tables try relying on it to determine
where the stock market is going and you
might as well throw your money down the
hole I'll discuss two examples to show
how possible and necessary it is to
quantify major uncertainties and risks
using the right methods in the first
example of AIG
he risks they knew about were not
quantified and were ignored in the
second example of the space shuttle key
risks were quantified but not acted on
because there was no supporting data
let's start with AIG they'll all recall
the great subprime mortgage boom in
which people got loans on little or no
documentation the lenders didn't care
because they prepackaged the loans
together and sold them to people who
could carve them up into into securities
and sell them on to other people part of
the reason this great shell game worked
was that people could buy what was
called a credit default swap or a CBS
which paid them if they didn't get paid
on the security AIG sold tens of
billions of dollars worth of these when
AIG looked at the risks of selling these
they knew they faced three risks first
they'd have to pay if there was a
default or non-payment on a security
second their credit rating would be
downgraded which could cost them in a
variety of ways
lastly they could be asked to put up
more collateral collateral to support
their ability to pay off a CBS the first
of these risks they analyzed using
historical data which was not
representative the tiny chances of
default they calculated were just junk
the other two risks they simply ignored
because there was no data to analyze in
the end it was the rating downgrades and
collateral calls which pushed AIG to the
brink of bankruptcy before the
government stepped in with a hundred
billion dollar bailout in the second
example of the space shuttle professor
Elizabeth pate Cornell of Stanford who
teaches in our program was asked in 1990
to analyze risk for the Space Shuttle
she focused in on the insulating heat
tiles on the bottom of the shuttle the
diagram shows how she put all the pieces
together to use what data there was and
to elicit expert judgments tiles could
be lost because they could be hit with
debris or glue failed additional
adjacent tiles could then be lost with
the intense heating on reentry if there
was burned through in those areas
the key subsystems underneath were lost
the shuttle could be lost
she used a combination of looking at all
the data and supplemented with expert
opinions expressed as the kind of
probability numbers we've been talking
about professor pate Cornell concluded
that lost tiles added up to the risk of
a total loss of the shuttle in one out
of every 100 flights here's the diagram
showing how critical the risk was on
every area underneath the shuttle
depending on what was underneath she
also concluded that 15% of the tiles
contributed 85% of the total risk and
that the risk of total failure could be
reduced by 70% at a very small cost in
contrast and analysis looking only at
the historical data concluded that the
risk of shuttle loss was only 1 in 3,000
flights but the problem was the sample
was too small after only 67 flights and
the results was unstable
professor patty Cornell was asked where
was the data supporting her figure for a
total loss of 1 out of 100 flights and
then NASA buried her study the missing
data occurred on February 1st 2003 when
the space shuttle Columbia burned up on
re-entry after tiles were damaged by
debris on takeoff for that tragic flight
NASA actually knew the damage on takeoff
had occurred but didn't spend much time
inspecting in orbit because there was
nothing they could do about it at that
point anyway I'll ask Hannah now to
conduct our next poll on whether your
organization quantifies uncertainties or
relies solely on historical data
analysis okay so in your organization
how do you quantify risks and
uncertainties
do you use only historical data you use
both historical data and subjective
estimates you use only subjective
estimates which or you evaluate
everything qualitatively but you don't
quantify them so go ahead and click next
to the box that best describes your
answer
great it looks like many of you are
responding so I'll go ahead and close
the polls and show the results it looks
like a vast majority of you use both
historical data and subjective estimates
and that's fantastic
Thank You Hannah a recap briefly on why
it is so important to quantify all major
risks and uncertainties first you don't
omit critical risks or uncertainties for
lack of data second you can make better
decisions explicitly considering these
uncertainties
lastly identifying which risks and
uncertainties have the greatest impact
on value creates new options for better
managing risk and increasing value let's
now delve a little deeper into why
focusing on risk and uncertainty allows
value protection and value creation
we'll pick up with the issues edhead for
the safe patient handling program at
Stanford for the safe patient handling
program at Stanford we put together a
comprehensive picture of all the sources
of value and risk using a combination of
the data IDI already showed you and
subjective estimates this is a picture
of all the risk and uncertainty factors
related together exactly the same kind
of diagram that professor pate Cornell
put together for the Space Shuttle but
just done for safe patient handling here
it is a little bit bigger so you can
read it for example we mentioned that we
know that the single biggest demands of
the single biggest reason that people
leave nursing is because of the physical
demands of the job if we can get one
nurse to stay because she no longer has
to physically handle patients we saved
the $60,000 cost to recruit and train a
new
nurse so for that issue we gathered all
the staff in a room and ask the
questions what is the smallest possible
impact we could have on turnover give us
a number and given how low the turnover
is at Stanford that answer was maybe
zero no impact at all and what is the
largest possible impact it was that
simple we just needed to quantify the
uncertainty we can then figure out which
uncertainties have the greatest impact
on total program value and have a hard
look at whether we believe the estimates
or could come up with some better ones
while we were at it we looked at all the
other things we could get out of state
patient handling which are all shown
here on this diagram could we reduce the
incidence of pressure ulcers could we
get more patient referrals because
patients feel greater dignity and
independence with being able to toilet
themselves and would not being heaved
into the MRI machine like a sack of
potatoes
this next chart shows the results of
taking all the quantified uncertainties
calculating the potential impact on
program value and arranging them from
biggest impact to smallest this sorting
gives the graph the shape of our tornado
which is why we call it that I also like
to call it a tornado because it shows
what could blow you away what it showed
was that the way to get the most
additional value out of safe patient
handling program was to work on the
turnover reduction if you could go from
the low estimate of no impact at all to
the high estimate of a 20% reduction in
the turnover at Stanford that would add
three and a half million dollars in
program value in contrast the reduction
in lost and restricted days and workers
comp were number six and seven on the
ranking of value drivers even though
these were all the program was initially
justified on then we went the next step
and looked at what happens when you vary
everything all at the same time because
that's reality all these uncertainties
will be varying all at the same time
this gives us probability distribution
on
total program value which is what we're
really after here's what the probability
distribution look like in terms of
internal rate of return if you look at
the lower left part of it you see that
in the worst case scenario where the
costs are the greatest and the benefits
are the least the program still has an
internal rate of return of 50 percent
that's versus the 27 percent internal
rate of return that was initially
calculated and the mean value of all
this uncertainty which is what we bet on
for decision-making purposes is a
hundred and eleven percent we can also
take that mean program value and break
it down into components of value which
is what this chart shows it's another
way to look at it and it's often easier
than reading a probability distribution
people love seeing the program laid out
in a chart like this but they're correct
but their question always is is it real
that's what quantifying the uncertainty
does for us we know the best case and
the worst case scenarios and we know we
can bet on a mean of that for
decision-making purposes and now let's
have Eddie tell us exactly how Stanford
used the event this identification of
key value drivers to get more value out
of their safe patient handling program
thanks John we are ending year one and
seeing the fruits of our labor we have
set up dashboards to track progress on
certain indicators and put in new
awareness measures that highlight the
save patient handling benefits to staff
and patients but first let's take a
quick survey before we go into the
results Hannah so we like to hear from
you again do your risk management
programs reveal how to create value yes
by design they focus only on loss
avoidance or we count less expensive
Lots avoidance of value creation or they
occasionally reveal a ways to create new
value or systematically you're looking
for ways to create new value or maybe
you thought about it but you still don't
know how to do it
please go ahead and choose the answer
that just describes how your
organization handles the risk management
program
great looks like many of you are sodding
so I'm going to go ahead and close the
polls and show the results looks like
most of you have thought about it but
don't know how to do it and then some of
you also another hi response with that
your programs occasionally reveal a way
to create new value but there definitely
seems like there's room for improvement
here thanks Anna here you'll see the
results have been measured thus far and
are plotted on our tornado good diagram
with the red arrow our overall cost of
workers compensation should have
increased due to several factors erosion
of current law increase in the cost for
medical and indemnity payments for
injured workers to name just a few
but instead of an increase we have had a
40 percent reduction in our workers
compensation costs in the area of State
patient handling which in turn had a
reduction in our lost day cost we have
also had the employee satisfaction
scores done by Gallup increased in
departments where the equipment was
implemented on the question I have the
tools and equipment necessary to do my
job
we actually experienced a 7% improvement
we also have comments from our patients
who told our staff they would come back
for necessary diagnostic tests because
we have the patient handling equipment
that moves them in a secure and
respectful manner we have now been
identified and recognized for this work
as a national best practice on how to
develop a business case for safe patient
handling this process has been published
in the new design and construction
guidelines for healthcare facilities on
overhead system installation
justification we were published in
ashram in the ashram monograph on value
driven erm and finally just last week we
won the Stanford Melinda s Mitchell
service and quality award and now I'll
turn it over to Jeff to tell us what all
this means for where healthcare erm is
going and why Jeff okay thank us and
thank you for all you've done for
Stanford and congratulations on your
award
in terms of where healthcare erm is
going typical erm roadmaps like the one
shown here do recognise the need to move
from a downside risk mitigation or value
protection focus to one that at least
equally focuses on value creation the
question is how one actually does that
board level involvement and sponsorship
plus integration with business planning
processes are certainly important but
suppose you're orbit and organization
actually has these the question is what
would the erm staff actually be doing to
create value this chart illustrates the
journey of Enterprise Risk Management
from purely transactional defensive risk
management to the more common advanced
management of risk deployed in modern
risk management programs today the Holy
Grail and Enterprise Risk Management is
to to move towards strategic risk
management that holistically deals with
not only the downside of risk but have
at least equal importance the upside of
risk you can see that in this cutting
edge model for Enterprise Risk
Management it is filled with good
phrases like support objectives and
capture opportunities but how exactly
would you do that as we discussed with
the last poll it's very hard to make the
connection from a traditional downside
loss of voidance focus to one that
includes the upside and value creation
what we actually see in most
organizations which have erm is that
they combine loss avoidance with some
sort of process for eliciting and
ranking risks usually in a risk register
or a heat map and then they plan
mitigation for what people agree are the
biggest risks two years ago the top of
everybody's risk register was avian flu
pandemic which never really happened now
at the top of everyone's risk register
as economic meltdown this has already
happened
suppose you have economic meltdown on
your risk register what do you actually
do about it and how do you know what you
get out of those efforts
to achieve the full potential of
enterprise risk management including
value creation
erm needs a frameshift to understanding
the uncertainty and value to do this at
Stanford we take a very concrete
approach we quantify the major risks and
uncertainties we develop comprehensive
alternatives for both mitigating risk
and creating value we quantify the range
of uncertainty from what we could get
out of different alternatives and use
that to guide the decision then we
monitor to make sure we are getting the
value anticipated and we watch for any
surprises with this approach there is no
difference in how one goes about
protecting value versus creating value
it's really all part of the same picture
it brings erm into the mainstream of how
we think about and run the organization
this is the direction that healthcare
erm needs to move to including value
creation and we're delighted to be part
of figuring out how to make that happen
with that I'll turn it over to Carissa
little to talk a little more about what
you might learn Thank You Geoff at the
Stanford center for professional
development we've been delivering
education to industry for over 40 years
so we have reasonable experience in
creating educational programs to meet
the career long learning needs of
professionals managers and executives
and industry here you can see the areas
where we offer part-time master's
degrees and certificates for graduate
credit you know many of these are
available entirely online and so that's
a great benefit to working professionals
and here are professional certificate
these are created to be very intensive
programs that are specifically geared
towards working professional we at the
Stanford center for professional
development are pleased to be working
with the strategic decisions group and
in partnership with Professor Ron Howard
who is the founder of the decision
analysis field and he's a faculty member
and
management science and engineering
department at Stanford we believe that
the strategic decision and risk
management program is a unique offering
because it blends the industry practical
experience from experts like Jeff Eadie
and John with the Stanford theory and
research resulting in a rigorous program
what we tried to do in creating this
program was offer courses via flexible
delivery options so participants can
either come to Stanford's campus in
March or September online via streaming
video at anytime or through the SDG
program where they come to your company
site to deliver courses for cohorts of
about 20 or more we've been hearing
about the challenges in this space from
the medical administration community for
quite some time and by collaborating
with the Stanford hospital risks
Consulting Group and the American
Society of healthcare risk management
we've been able to introduce a new
course strategic decision making to
manage risk in healthcare organizations
this led to our creating a new emphasis
on health care as an option for the
strategic decision and risk management
certificate program you'll see the new
emphasis requires four courses including
decision out analysis decision quality
collaborative decision making and
negotiation as well as the new course we
believe that the program here allows
leaders to make significant changes in
enterprise management within the
healthcare industry here you can see the
calendar which has the dates for the
march on campus events and when the core
and elective courses are offered as well
as some pricing details we also have an
early registration discount if you sign
up by February 1st for the March courses
or you'll save approximately $200 per
course we would also like to point out
that ashram is making available a number
of educational grants to their members
for the new course strategic decision
making to manage risk in healthcare
organizations please visit their website
to apply there are both full and partial
grants available and though they'll be
awarded on a first-come first-served
basis if
are interested in that you mean once
asked quickly and with that we'd like to
ask for your feedback on one final poll
if you could please indicate your level
of interest in the new emphasis in
health care for the strategic decision
or risk management certificate program
and we'll just wait a few minutes for
the results to come in we really
appreciate your feedback on this
question that helps us determine how
frequently we'll offer these new these
new courses okay thank you so much and
with that I will turn it over to Hanna
who will help facilitate our Q&A period
Thank You Karissa we've answered some of
the questions that you've sent in by
text that they've come in and you've
seen them show up in the queue but if
you came up that we thought we would ask
the presenters to discuss so the first
question that we had was how does your
system relate to ISO 31000 principles of
risk management
so the ISO 31000
standards lays out a lot of definitions
and taxonomy for risk management it also
lays out a risk management process that
risk management process is fairly
generic in which you you have a risk
assessment where you need to identify
risks you need to analyze risks you need
to evaluate them and then you need to
treat them and then monitoring and
review goes along with that the the risk
manage that we're talking about here is
identical at a process level the
question is how do you go about
analyzing and evaluating your risks and
what we've given you today is a taste of
some of what we feel is a better
methodology both for analyzing and
evaluating risks and for broadening your
focus to are including uncertainties in
addition to what people traditionally
think of as risks
great thank you now we had a couple
questions on the tornado the first
question of the tornado chart was what
program did you use to create that chart
so that program was actually created in
an application called super tree which
will produce probability distributions
and the tornado chart and there is a
student version of that that you can
download for free to try out there's a
number of other applications that do it
and some people even just do it in Excel
the process is fairly simple in that you
need to define an input with this range
of numbers that we're talking about and
then you just change which one of those
numbers you do and you're using in the
calculation and you keep track of the
result and plot it so there there are a
number of software choices to do it but
you could actually do it yourself in
Excel and some people some people do
that
so I would also mention that at Stanford
within the risk management department we
have about 20 people we've loaded super
tree up onto the desktops of our
employees so they can actually go in and
do this kind of analysis and become
quite familiar and weave it into our
practices and it's it's received wide
acceptance in the risk management
department and folks really love to use
it great thank you and one more question
we had about the tornado what is the
scale of the impact ask from experts let
me let me see if I understand the
question there's a there's two parts to
that question so first is what do we ask
the experts when we're asking the
questions and when we ask them a series
of three questions what's a number that
is low enough that you think it's
extremely unlikely reality would be
lower than this
we'll say there's a 10% chance that it
could be lower so not a crazy load
number but a number low enough you'd be
surprised if it was less than this then
likewise on the high side we ask what's
the number high enough that you think
there's only a 10% chance the actual
would be higher and we ask to lay out a
number for that and then lastly we say
give me your 50/50 so what's a number
where you think it's it's equally likely
reality would be above or below this so
what this does is it lets us ask the
expert for a range on the uncertainty
and then the impact is a calculated
number so we have to build a little
model of how each of the inputs
translates through to a value measure
like we did for change and turnover for
every person you don't turn over you
save $60,000 and then the result of
taking that experts guess and then
tracking it through to the the
calculated impact on value is what we
show on the tornado diagram great thanks
John another question how do we as risk
managers convince senior leadership how
important erm is there's a struggle to
sell the strategic erm program is
paramount to the organization but it's
really as important as corporate
compliance so how do we convince senior
leadership about this so I think that's
a very good point in a important
question because you know we are all
competing for sort of tough resources
and the way we've done it at Stanford is
we sort of started small with a
demonstration project if you will and
then once you can show success using
these methods you can build from there
and then start weaving into other
projects and then really on that
continuum beginning to move it forward
into the organization success breeds
success so we think there is a great
return on weaving these methodologies
into your program really need to be
reasonable start small build and move on
from there
thanks Jeff
so this is a little bit of the opposite
of starting small we had a question from
someone who says I work in a facility
with 515 licensed beds and I'm the only
risk manager or patient safety officer
how can I be effective in an institution
of this size well I think when you're
when you wear a lot of hats you're very
busy
it's sort of like command and control
and one of the things you have to do is
look at who can help you and enthusiast
processes into your organization one
person certainly can't do it all but I
think if with the the right use of
people that can help you you can get it
done and you can make it happen so you
just have to really think about who you
bring in to help in that situation
because certainly there's a lot on the
risk managers plate and I like to sort
of envision a play you have to think
about taking some some things off the
plate so you can make room for other
important strategic work great thanks
Jeff now another question on the
analysis why did you use IRR or internal
rate of return instead of NPV or net
present value we used internal rate of
return mainly because the the Finance
Group that does that works with the
Capitol Committee has set up a process
internally and they're their tool that
they use specifically calls for an
internal rate of return to do cost
justification for any capital projects
so your organization may look at
internal rate of return it may look at
net present value it just learn to work
within your current structure and
processes to get the program sold so
that you can make the best business case
depending on how they're set up so that
could change and vary from organization
to organization okay great another
question how could a prejudice toward
utilizing forensic data be bridged for
those who have trouble digesting
projected or uncertain
uncertainty related data well for that I
think you have to make the case that we
were making in the webinar today which
is that the answer to everything can't
be found in historical data and people
definitely have a very strong bias
towards relying on historical data and
it's absolutely necessary to use
forensic data wherever it's possible you
just have to be aware of the limitations
of that data and to realize that there's
this other perspective for capturing a
lot of what people what I call people's
common sense about what's going on and
the impacts of things that you can't
represent by doing an analysis on a
particular data set so the examples what
kind of examples that I give to people
to explain this include things like the
weather forecast example that we talked
about today another example I'll often
use is the choice between picking a
fixed rate mortgage versus a variable
rate mortgage and guess what a variable
rate mortgage depends on a future
uncertainty called
interest rates in the future and there
isn't any historical data which will
tell you for sure what interest rates in
the future are going to be so people
need to realize that as as necessary as
it is to look at all the data that you
have the answers to the questions you
really want to know is not in historical
data and relying only on historical data
is like driving your car by looking only
in the rearview mirror if the road is
straight it's ok but it's pretty easy to
end up in the ditch great thanks John
we're going to take one more question
the rest will answer by text at the
after the session is over
so one of the questions that we were
asked is what other statistical
techniques like Monte Carlo simulation
can be used to quantify risk and how do
these results combine with the
subjective estimates
well a Monte Carlo simulation is really
just another way of calculating the
numbers because and if you if you know
what you're doing you can use these
subjective estimates as an input to a
Monte Carlo simulation because it does
the same thing it just puts in different
sets of data inputs and it calculates a
number the problem that most people have
using Monte Carlo simulations is it's
very easy to do garbage in garbage out
in this approach where we are looking at
a tornado diagram first to figure out
what the key uncertainties are it really
focuses attention on the uncertainties
that make the most difference and
whether those are the best estimates
that we can get or we can we have a
better expert or get a better estimate
the biggest problem with Monte Carlo is
that it's very easy just to do plus or
minus 5% plus or minus 10% on all the
inputs to the Monte Carlo it produces a
beautiful s-curve no matter what you put
in so it makes it very easy for people
to not think about those uncertainty
ranges and to just turn the crank and
out of that you get no insight at all
thanks John
we're going to answer the remaining
questions at the end of the session by
text and so now I'd like to finish up
here by thanking you ladies and
gentlemen for participating in today's
webinar this concludes today's session
as a reminder you may download a PDF of
the slides by clicking on the handouts
icon in the menu bar selecting the file
and clicking download as Carissa
mentions our next set of on-campus
courses will be from March 14th through
25th we hope you can join us then our
new course in strategic decision-making
can manage risk and healthcare
organizations will be held for March
21st to the 23rd that's one of the four
required courses for this new
certificate emphasis in healthcare the
other three are decision analysis
decision quality and organizations and
enterprise risk management so all four
of those required courses
will be offered in March and most of
them are available online as well and
with as with any of our other online
courses this the online option works
better for you you can access most of
our courses anytime anywhere we thank
you for joining us